This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Throughout its reign, the British Empire stole a lot of stuff. Today, those objects are housed in Jenteel institutions across the UK and the world. They usually come with polite plaques. The Australian podcast Stuff the British Stole is a six episode series about the not-so-polite history behind a few of those objects. I completely fell in love with the show, so we're going to play the first episode and
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。在其统治期间，大英帝国掠夺了许多东西。如今，这些物品存放在英国乃至世界各地的温和机构中。它们通常配有礼貌的铭牌。澳大利亚播客节目《那些英国人偷走的东西》是一部六集的系列节目，讲述了其中几件物品背后的那些不太客气的历史。我深深地爱上了这个节目，所以我们将播放第一集，并
talk to the presenter and creator, Mark Fanell, about the series. Here's Stuff the British Store. Is I same kind of dead? Like, he should be screaming. I mean, the guys being molded by a tiger like he should be screaming. I mean, the guy's being mulled by a tiger, blood should be everywhere, but the floor is completely dry. And his eyes seem serene,
与该节目的主持人兼创作者马克·范内尔（Mark Fennell）聊聊这个系列。以下是《那些英国人偷走的东西》。这是一种死去的姿态吗？就像，他应该在尖叫。我的意思是，那家伙被老虎撕咬，他应该在尖叫。我是说，这家伙被老虎撕咬，血应该到处都是，但地板完全是干的。而他的眼神显得宁静，
his mouth curved to almost a smile. Like, even in death, he knows he's one. It's intrinsically a kind of, you know, dramatic and very bloody event. The taiga's roaring, the man's screaming. It's shameless. It's so blatant. I mean, if somebody, you know, literally dug your father's grave up
他的嘴角弯起，几乎带着微笑。就像，即使在死后，他也知道自己赢了。这本质上是一种戏剧性且非常血腥的事件。老虎在咆哮，人在尖叫。这太无耻了。太明目张胆了。我的意思是，如果有人，你知道的，字面意思上挖了你父亲的坟墓，
and put it on display in his backyard, I mean, it's that kind of story you talk about. You talk about, you talk about, you talk about. On the 3rd of December 2019, London was sunny. I mean, bloody freezing, but the sky was this absolute crisp blue. You could see high above the city three, four planes crisscrossing the sky. One of which I'd be on in a matter of hours. The city was already decked out with tinsels and bobbles and there were puffer-jacketed office workers cramming themselves into witsy department stores. And then, there was me.
然后把它摆在他后院供人参观，我的意思是，这就是你会谈论的那种故事。你会谈论，你会谈论，你会谈论。2019年12月3日，伦敦阳光明媚。我是说，冷得要命，但天空是绝对清澈的蓝色。你可以看到城市高空有三四架飞机在空中交错飞行。其中一架我将在几小时后登上。这座城市已经挂满了金属丝和装饰球，穿着羽毛球服的上班族们挤进了繁华的百货公司。然后，是我。
Virtually alone in this cavernous museum hall struggling to understand why no one was taking notice of the almost life-size soldier with the dilated pupils of a career stoner, lying supine as a wild, orange tiger plunged its fangs deep into the side of his neck. When we go to museums and we see these objects on display, we can sort of see the notes that they make as they're trying to tell those stories. Exactly which notes is history playing here. You can see the depth of interest. When they were in the city there was hand-to-hand fighting in the streets.
几乎独自一人在这个巨大的博物馆大厅里，努力去理解为什么没有人注意到这个几乎与真人大小相当的士兵，他散大着一个职业瘾君子的瞳孔，仰面躺着，而一只凶猛的橙色老虎将尖牙深深刺入他的脖子侧面。当我们去博物馆看到这些展出的物品时，我们大概能看到他们在试图讲述这些故事时留下的注解。历史在这里扮演的究竟是哪种注解呢。你可以看到兴趣的深度。当他们在城里时，街头发生了白刃战。
King is vanquished and he's in bad form. The thing is when Christian and his parents were so far from the government. People get defensive and they get uncomfortable and a lot of people walk away at that way. They see nothing wrong with their behaviour. Everything that you take for granted about your history, you go left here today. It's not necessarily true. That's probably the moment it occurred to me. The crime I was witnessing, it wasn't murder. It was theft. I'm Mark Fennel and this is Stuff the British Style. How long you are staying, sir? I'm flying back tonight. Just tonight.
国王被击败了，他的处境很糟。问题是，当克里斯蒂安和他的父母远离政府时。人们会变得戒备，感到不适，很多人会选择那样走开。他们认为自己的行为没有任何问题。你对历史的一切理所当然的看法，今天在这里全盘皆非。那不一定是真的。那可能是我突然意识到的时刻。我目睹的罪行不是谋杀。那是偷窃。我是马克·范内尔，这就是《那些英国人偷走的东西》。先生，你要待多久？我今晚就飞回去。就今晚。
Tonight, yeah. I'm just driving around trying to get presents for my kids. I'm only shopping. So in some ways, this whole thing starts a few hours earlier with me being interrogated by London cab driver who found my face, particularly the color of it, extremely confusing. You are also looking at the ancient meias from there?
今晚，是的。我只是开车到处想给我的孩子们买礼物。我只是在购物。所以在某种程度上，这一切从几个小时前就开始了，我被一个伦敦出租车司机盘问，他觉得我的脸，尤其是它的颜色，极其令人困惑。你也是在看那里的古代美索不达米亚文明吗？
My mom is from Singapore, but she's Indian, and my dad is from Ireland. From Ireland. Yeah, so I'm a weird mixture of both. And you born in Australia, you move from here to... No, no. And Australian citizen, and I'm an Irish citizen, and I grew up in Australia,
我妈妈来自新加坡，但她是印度人，我爸爸来自爱尔兰。来自爱尔兰。是的，所以我是一个奇怪的混合体。你是在澳大利亚出生的，你从这里搬到……不，不。我是澳大利亚公民，我也是爱尔兰公民，我在澳大利亚长大，
and I'm Indian ethnically, but Mum from Singapore so it's all a bit. You have less than a little bit worth of. I think my Mum can swear in India and that's about it. She definitely can and it is brutal. It's also true that I tend to think of myself as the worst kind of ethnic. I don't speak any other languages. Now accents, no real understanding of my own history. That's it. I can cook and more importantly, I still count towards your diversity quota. I work for the ABC, which is like the BBC, but for Australia. You are like a reporter, like a... I sort of travel a lot to do.
从族裔上讲我是印度人，但我妈妈来自新加坡，所以这一切都有点。你甚至有点不。我想我妈妈会用印地语说脏话，仅此而已。她绝对会，而且那太粗鲁了。同样真实的是，我往往认为自己是最糟糕的那种族裔。我不会说其他任何语言。没有口音，对自己的历史也没有真正的了解。就是这样。我会做饭，更重要的是，我仍然符合你们的多元化配额。我为澳大利亚广播公司（ABC）工作，这就像英国广播公司（BBC），但属于澳大利亚。你就像一个记者，就像一个……我经常到处旅行去。
I interview lots of people around the world, so that's what I do. I used to go to India as well. You know, I've never been to India. Never been. No, I've never been. It's a surprise for me. Why not all over the world you are traveling?
我采访世界各地的许多人，这就是我的工作。我以前也去过印度。你知道，我从来没去过印度。从没去过。没有，我从来没去过。这对我来说是个惊喜。为什么全世界你都在旅行？
For some reason, it is your mum's homeland. I know, it's terrible. I've never been. There's no real reason. I've never been. There's no real reason I just never, I've never been for some reason. And with my cultural shaming now complete, he drops me outside Houston station
不知何故，那是你妈妈的祖国。我知道，这太糟糕了。我从来没去过。没有什么真正的原因。我从来没去过。没有什么真正的原因，只是我从来没有，由于某种原因我从来没去过。随着我的文化羞辱现在完成，他在尤斯顿车站把我放下，
for the last meeting I have before heading to the airport. Of course. Hi. Nice to meet you. Alice, let me to meet you? This is the person that would lead me to watch a man being murdered by a tiger. She'd also send me to a dog kennel and a tattoo parlour but she doesn't know that yet and neither do I.
这是我去机场前的最后一次会面。当然。嗨。很高兴见到你。爱丽丝，很高兴见到你？这就是那个带我去观看一个男人被老虎谋杀的人。她还会把我送到狗舍和纹身店，但她现在还不知道，我也不知道。
What I do know is that accent sounds familiar. Did you go up and mundin? Mostly. Yeah. Yeah. It's the fact that most sounds a lot like my parents. And where are your parents from? Adelaide. Ah, that's what it that I found a lot like my parents. And where are your parents from? Adelaide.
我所知道的是那个口音听起来很熟悉。你在芒丁长大吗？大部分是。是的。是的。事实是，大多数声音听起来很像我的父母。你的父母来自哪里？阿德莱德。啊，这就是我发现它听起来很像我父母的原因。你的父母来自哪里？阿德莱德。
Ah, that's what it is. That's what it is. Okay. We left Australia when I was very, very young and I grew up in Hong Kong. And then I've been in London most of my life. So I went to school here, I've studied here. And that's kind of part of the reason I've spent so much time in museums is moving here. My parents were like, we're going to be in the heart of culture and history, so we're going to make sure you actually take advantage of that. Alice A. Proctor. With an E is a very different kind of historian.
啊，原来是这样。原来是这样。好的。我们很小的时候就离开了澳大利亚，我在香港长大。然后我一生的大部分时间都在伦敦度过。所以我在这里上过学，在这里学习过。这也是我花这么多时间在博物馆的原因的一部分，因为搬到了这里。我的父母觉得，我们将身处文化和历史的中心，所以我们要确保你真正利用这一点。爱丽丝·A·普罗特（Alice A. Proctor）。名字里带个E的她是一位非常与众不同的历史学家。
She specialises in the uncomfortable, which may explain why she wanted to meet in a library, which best way I know how to describe it is that it's halfway between Hogwarts and an actual horror movie. So this is part of the Welcome Collection, so it's a history of science and medicine. They have a bunch of bizarre and terrifying paintings of like 17th century medical procedures and stuff. There is a picture over there of a guy that appears to be flying off a chunk of his own flesh. And how would you describe that facial expression? Paint? Just a little bit.
她专门研究令人不安的事物，这也许可以解释为什么她想在一个图书馆见面，我所能形容它的最好方式是，它介于霍格沃茨和真正的恐怖电影之间。所以这是威康收藏馆的一部分，这是一部科学和医学史。他们有一堆奇特而可怕的绘画，比如17世纪的医疗程序之类的。那边有一张画，画的是一个人似乎正在割掉自己的一块肉。你会如何形容那种面部表情？画吗？只是一点点。
Alice gives guided tours, just not the ones that museums and galleries like. Basically, when I started doing the tours, they were proper undercover secret tours, which means that most... Undercover history, I love it. Most of the museums didn't find out about me until I started getting press attention.
爱丽丝提供导游服务，只是不是博物馆和画廊喜欢的那种。基本上，当我开始做这些导游时，它们是真正的卧底秘密导游，这意味着大多数……卧底历史，我喜欢。直到我开始受到媒体关注，大多数博物馆才发现我。
So for a lot of them, by the time they knew what I was doing, it was sort of too late to stop me. They're not wonder. Why is this girl with the funny Australian accent wondering around with a group of people around her? Like, did they just think you had a magnetic personality? They thought I was just a regular tour guide, right? And so I knew that you could do this because I've been a regular tour guide, and people would look at me and they would think,
所以对他们中的很多人来说，等他们知道我在做什么时，阻止我已经为时已晚。他们不会觉得奇怪。为什么这个有着有趣澳大利亚口音的女孩周围跟着一群人四处闲逛？就像，他们只是觉得你很有磁场吗？他们以为我只是个普通的导游，对吧？所以我知道你可以做到这一点，因为我当过普通导游，人们看着我，他们会觉得，
oh yes, she's a nice white girl with an art history background, she's probably an official educator, it'll be fine. And no one would actually stop and listen to what I was talking about. But when people did stop to listen at places like, say, the British Museum or the Victoria and Albert Museum or the V&A for short, some of the oldest collections on Earth. What did they hear? Specifically about the stuff that people don't want to talk about, which is colonial history, the kind of darkest parts of empire and imperialism. You know, these objects on display that have really violent histories. And no one would mention that.
哦，是的，她是一个有着艺术史背景的漂亮白人女孩，她可能是一个官方教育工作者，这没关系。而且没有人会真正停下来听我在谈论什么。但是当人们在诸如大英博物馆、维多利亚和阿尔伯特博物馆（简称V&A）这样地球上最古老的收藏馆停下来倾听时。他们听到了什么？具体关于人们不想谈论的事情，也就是殖民历史、帝国和帝国主义最黑暗的部分。你知道，这些展出的物品有着非常暴力的历史。没有人会提到这一点。
And also objects that have, quote unquote, contested histories. Or... Yeah, there's a euphemism. Right, exactly. And so a lot of museums use this term of contested histories as this way of kind of glossing over what's actually being contested, which is that nine times out of ten, they were stolen in very violent circumstances or taken as part of looting after conflict, that sort of thing.
还有那些有着，姑且称之为，有争议的历史的物品。或者……是的，这是一个委婉的说法。对，没错。因此，许多博物馆使用“有争议的历史”这个词，作为一种掩饰实际争议的方式，也就是十有八九，它们是在非常暴力的环境下被盗的，或者是作为冲突后的掠夺品被拿走的，诸如此类。
How many objects would you say sit in British institutions that you would classify as stolen? So it's actually impossible to put a number on it because most estimates would say that a gallery like the British Museum or the V&A or one of those other institutions, usually they've got about five to ten percent of their collection on display at any given time. So there is so much stuff that's not on show and often it's really hard to even kind of access the catalogs of the stuff that's not on show. So we honestly don't know how many hundreds of pieces there are that might be contested. And that is when Alice mentions the tiger.
你认为英国机构里有多少你归类为被盗的物品？所以实际上不可能给出一个数字，因为大多数估计会说，像大英博物馆或V&A或其中其他机构这样的画廊，通常在任何给定时间展出的藏品只占总数的百分之五到百分之十左右。所以有太多的东西没有展出，而且通常很难甚至查阅那些未展出藏品的目录。所以我们老实说不知道可能有数百件甚至更多的争议藏品。就在那时，爱丽丝提到了那只老虎。
Basically, it's a life-size wooden tiger, mollying a life-size wooden man dressed in the uniform of the East India Company. So it's very, very unsuttle. And when you crank the handle, it sort of makes screaming and groaning noises. Super classy. It's incredible. The Tiger has a name, Tipu's Tiger, named after a very real Indian ruler by the name of Tipu Sultaran.
基本上，这是一只真人大小的木制老虎，正在撕咬一个穿着东印度公司制服的真人大小的木制人。所以这是非常非常不低调的。当你摇动把手时，它会发出尖叫和呻吟的声音。超级高档。这太不可思议了。这只老虎有个名字，蒂普之虎（Tipu's Tiger），以一个名叫蒂普·苏丹（Tipu Sultan）的真实印度统治者命名。
The Tiger was his personal symbol. And a badass one at that. So the way Alice tells the story. The Tiger was first found back in 1799 and this tippu character was at war with the British, it seems he was killed and the British take his city and then the British soldiers. Go absolutely wild for three days, destroying stuff, looting stuff and only after three days is order restored and the official looting can begin. Official looting apparently being an accepted thing. And, and the official looting can begin.
这只老虎是他的个人象征。而且是一个非常硬核的象征。所以爱丽丝讲这个故事的方式是。这只老虎最早在1799年被发现，这个叫蒂普的角色当时与英国人交战，看起来他被杀害了，英国人攻占了他的城市，然后英国士兵。疯狂了三天，破坏东西，掠夺东西，只有在三天后秩序才得以恢复，官方掠夺才能开始。官方掠夺显然是一件被接受的事情。而且，官方掠夺可以开始了。
Official looting, apparently, being an accepted thing. And so when the official looting starts, they find this tiger, and it's made of wood, so it's not got any material value, whereas stuff like tipu's throne is broken down because it's made of gold, and it's more valuable in fritz material than fritz design. So the tiger survives in this very weird way because people don't think it's valuable enough and they say they're going to send it to London to be put on display. Over the years, Tippie's tiger ends up bouncing to a few different British museums and libraries. It goes down particularly badly at a library. So they have all these letters in the archives of students who are like,
官方掠夺，显然是一件被接受的事情。因此，当官方掠夺开始时，他们发现了这只老虎，它是木头做的，所以没有任何物质价值，而像蒂普的王座这样的东西因为是黄金做的而被拆毁了，比起它的设计，它的材质更有价值。所以这只老虎以这种非常奇怪的方式幸存下来，因为人们认为它不够有价值，他们说要把它送到伦敦展出。多年来，蒂普之虎最终辗转于几个不同的英国博物馆和图书馆。它在一个图书馆里的遭遇尤为糟糕。所以他们在档案馆里有所有这些学生的信件，他们写道：
I'm trying to use your library collection, but people keep coming in and making the tiger roar. And it's really disruptive to my studying. And for a while, they think about taking it off open display because people are fainting in horror at the site of it, because apparently it's so frightening. So it's got this very weird history once it comes to the UK. And now it's in the Victoria and Albert Museum, which is a design museum. In case you're wondering, fainting in horror
我正试图使用你们的图书馆藏品，但人们总是进来让老虎咆哮。这真的干扰了我的学习。有一段时间，他们考虑把它从公开展示中撤下，因为人们在看到它时吓得昏厥过去，因为显然它太吓人了。所以它来到英国后有着非常奇怪的历史。现在它在维多利亚和阿尔伯特博物馆，这是一个设计博物馆。如果你在纳闷，吓得昏厥
was the exact moment I decided that even with the rapidly closing window to get to Heathrow Airport, I had to see this thing. Which brings us to the beginning of this episode. Me alone in a cavernous room at the Victoria and Albert Museum, watching a near-life-sized British soldier made from Indian jackwood, being murdered by the badass personal symbol of Tipu Sultana. Honestly, standing there, all you wanna do is smash open that glass
正是我决定即使赶往希思罗机场的时间已经所剩无几，也必须亲眼看看这东西的准确时刻。这就把我们带到了这一集的开头。我一个人在维多利亚和阿尔伯特博物馆一个巨大的房间里，看着一个由印度杰克木制成的、接近真人大小的英国士兵，被蒂普·苏丹那个硬核的个人象征所谋杀。老实说，站在那里，你只想砸碎那块玻璃，
and crank this faded brass handle just so you can hear this sound. So about 11 years ago, the V&A invited a classically trained musician to attempt to play the tiger. They posted it on YouTube, which is where this clip comes from. They even opened up the tiger's guts, and inside it reveals this row of copper-colored pipes where his ribcage would be, and leather bellows. Lungs really. Pumping out these musical screams. The wildest part, as he plays, the mangled British soldiers arms automatically fly in agony.
然后摇动这个褪色的黄铜把手，只为了听到这个声音。大约11年前，V&A邀请了一位受过古典训练的音乐家试图弹奏这只老虎。他们把它发到了YouTube上，这个片段就是从那里来的。他们甚至打开了老虎的内部，里面露出一排铜色的管子，也就是它的肋骨所在的地方，还有皮革风箱。实际上就是肺。发出这些音乐般的尖叫声。最疯狂的部分是，当他演奏时，那个被撕裂的英国士兵的手臂会在痛苦中自动飞舞。
What the hell happened to this typical guy? Why would he want to make something like this? Uh, I have kept travel diaries for trips I've taken throughout my whole life. And the first one that I have is from the age of five. I write down that I've gone to the V&A, and I saw a funny object of a tiger killing an Englishman. No! Yeah. You're kidding. That's amazing. It makes a huge impression even if you're like a five year old kid, you know, being put in front of this.
这个叫蒂普的家伙到底怎么了？他为什么要制造这样东西？呃，我为我一生中进行的旅行保留了旅行日记。我拥有的第一本是从五岁开始的。我记下我去了V&A，我看到了一个老虎杀死英国人的有趣物品。不！是的。你在开玩笑吧。这太棒了。它留下了巨大的印象，即使你像一个五岁的小孩，你知道的，被放在这个东西面前。
You're hearing the voice of Maya Jazzinot. Recording and here we go. I am a history professor at Harvard University and I teach and write on the history of the British Empire. Where does your interest in India begin? My interest in India begins with my birth because I am myself half-India. My mother is from Calcutta
你听到的是玛雅·贾齐诺（Maya Jasanoff）的声音。录音，我们开始。我是哈佛大学的历史学家，我教授并撰写关于大英帝国历史的文章。你对印度的兴趣是从哪里开始的？我对印度的兴趣始于我的出生，因为我本人有一半印度血统。我母亲来自加尔各答，
and immigrated to the United States as a girl. And Maya has also become somewhat obsessed with this tiger and the man who owned it. Tipasolton was a prominent ruler in South India in the second half of the 18th century. He was one of the fiercest opponents of continued British expansion in the Indian subcontinent. I feel like you've done this before.
还是个女孩时就移民到了美国。玛雅也变得有点痴迷于这只老虎和拥有它的人。蒂普·苏丹是18世纪下半叶南印度的杰出统治者。他是英国继续在印度次大陆扩张最坚定的反对者之一。我觉得你以前做过这个。
I actually haven't, but I can whip it out. So Tipu made a kind of fetish out of the tiger. The tiger, of course, is indigenous to India. So his soldiers wore uniforms that had a kind of tiger stripe on them, tigers on the pommles of his swords, and you know, just sort of tiger motifs everywhere around him. It was his badge. I can't find real photos of Tippu, but the illustrations that we do have show a slightly chubby, strong-drawered man with a turban and a delicately coved moustache, always
我其实没有，但我可以把它拿出来。所以蒂普把老虎当成了一种图腾。老虎当然是印度本土的动物。所以他的士兵穿着印有老虎条纹的制服，他的剑柄上有老虎，你知道的，他周围到处都是老虎的图案。这是他的徽章。我找不到蒂普的真实照片，但我们拥有的插图显示了一个微胖、下巴结实、戴着头巾、留着精致胡须的男人，总是
upturned. But what the pictures don't tell you is that this man spent every second of his 17-year-round court in a series of strange balancing acts. The story of Tipu Sultan is one of a man who found himself between two superpowers, two huge revolutions, and between two generations, his father and his sons. So if he started, Tipu Sultana spent his life carrying out someone else's unfinished business, the business of his dad. A man called Hyder Ali. The two of them I think need to be understood together to some extent because Tipu was really building on what his father had started.
向上翘起。但这些照片没有告诉你的是，这个男人17年统治生涯的每一秒都在一系列奇怪的平衡中度过。蒂普·苏丹的故事是一个发现自己夹在两个超级大国、两场巨大革命以及两代人（他的父亲和他的儿子们）之间的男人的故事。所以如果他开始了，蒂普·苏丹一生都在完成别人未竟的事业，他父亲的事业。一个名叫海德·阿里（Hyder Ali）的男人。我认为在某种程度上，他们两个需要被放在一起理解，因为蒂普确实是在他父亲开始的基础上建立起来的。
And what his father had started was a dynasty. An opulent one, too. From the southwest coast to deep inland, they themselves were Muslim leaders, but they ruled sometimes brutally over both Hindus and Christians. They overthrew existing leaders and they were on a hunt for more land, more people, and more power. But in the course of doing this, run into some of the other powers that were interested in grabbing a piece of the action and those powers included most notably the East India Company. The East India Company. In effect, a commercial army in service of the British Empire.
而他父亲开始的是一个王朝。一个富丽堂皇的王朝。从西南海岸到内陆深处，他们本身是穆斯林领袖，但他们有时对印度教徒和基督徒进行残酷的统治。他们推翻了现有的领导者，他们渴望更多的土地、更多的人民和更多的权力。但在这样做的过程中，遇到了其他一些对分一杯羹感兴趣的力量，这些力量中最显著的包括东印度公司。东印度公司。实际上，是为大英帝国服务的商业军队。
Hider found himself in conflict with the East India Company repeatedly in a series of wars, which resulted in, among other things, him taking a whole bunch of captives from the British army and holding them in the capital city of Seringapatam. By the time Tipu's father, Haida Ali had died and Tipu himself assumed power, the British, they were angry, very angry.
海德发现自己在一系列战争中与东印度公司发生了一再的冲突，这些战争导致的结果之一就是他从英国军队中俘虏了一大群人，并将他们关押在首都塞林加帕坦姆（Seringapatam）。当蒂普的父亲海德·阿里去世，蒂普本人登基时，英国人愤怒了，非常愤怒。
Haida Ali died, Tipu Sultan inherited the throne and with it inherited this legacy of being in a, you know, up and coming-coming kingdom that had successfully defeated the British and was holding British officers in captivity. And the British started to kind of build up this whole rhetorical, you know, picture of these people as these Muslim despots. And it was fueled by accounts that were coming from the captives from Seringapatam, who came out with these tales of things like, I was forcibly circumcised, or I was forced to dress up in women's clothes and dance before the king. And out of all of this, emerged this kind of demonization of these two figures,
海德·阿里去世了，蒂普·苏丹继承了王位，随之继承了这样一个传奇：他处于一个蒸蒸日上的王国，这个王国成功地击败了英国人，并将英国军官扣为人押。英国人开始建立一整套修辞画像，把这些人描绘成穆斯林暴君。这是由来自塞林加帕坦姆的俘虏的讲述所助长的，他们带着诸如“我被强行割礼”或“我被迫穿上女装在国王面前跳舞”之类的事情的故事走出来。在这一切之中，出现了对这两个人物的一种妖魔化，
Hyder and Tipu, as people to be feared, because they actually had beaten the British. as people to be feared because they actually had beaten the British. Even to this day, there are so many competing narratives about Tipu Sultan. He remains one of the most controversial figures in Indian history. And right now, a deeply political one, too. I just get you to introduce yourself and what you do for a living. I'm Shashu Faroo, I I'm a third-term member of the Indian Parliament. I had a 29-year career at the United Nations, ending as under Secretary-General under Gelfi Yaman. I have published 20 books with two more do-outs before the end of the year.
海德和蒂普，作为令人害怕的人，因为他们实际上击败了英国人。作为令人害怕的人，因为他们实际上击败了英国人。直到今天，关于蒂普·苏丹仍有许多相互竞争的叙述。他仍然是印度历史中最具争议的人物之一。而现在，也是一个深深政治化的人物。请你介绍一下你自己以及你是靠什么谋生的。我是沙希·塔鲁尔（Shashi Tharoor），我是印度议会第三届议员。我在联合国度过了29年的职业生涯，最后担任杰菲·杨曼（Gelfi Yaman）手下的副秘书长。我出版了20本书，还有两本将在年底前出版。
And I'm an amateur fan of modern Indian history. Pretty sure after 20 books, you no longer qualify as amateur, but we'll let that one slide. What I happen to have a slightly unfashionable view in India today, that he was a hero. And that's largely because he was a resolute anti-colonialist. I say it's a slightly unfashionable view because there are also a lot of accounts, both in terms of British records which may be biased, but also folklore and tales passed down the generations of his rather gruesome persecution of large numbers of Hindus and Christians, which have not endeared him to descendants of those communities.
我是现代印度历史的业余爱好者。我敢肯定，在写了20本书之后，你不再有资格被称为业余爱好者，但我们会放过这一点。我碰巧在今天的印度有一个有点过时的观点，即他是一个英雄。这主要是因为他是一个坚定的反殖民主义者。我说这是一个有点过时的观点，因为也有很多说法，既有可能是出于偏见的英国记录，也有代代相传的民间传说和故事，讲述了他对大量印度教徒和基督徒的相当可怕的迫害，这并没有使他受到这些社群后代的喜爱。
Literally as Shashi and I talk, there is a campaign effort within India to remove Tipu from parts of the school syllabus because of his massacring of Hindu subjects. And yet, curiously, for very Hindu politician Shashi Tarur, I would, on the whole, regard them as someone whom Indians by and large are very good reason to be proud of. Mysore was a formidable state, extending across the largest portions imaginable of southern India, people of his kingdom of Mysore, enjoyed the highest standards of living in the known world, the per capita income, was higher than the highest European power at the time of the Dutch. Very well-armed, high technological capacity,
就在沙希和我交谈的时候，印度国内正在开展一场运动，因为蒂普屠杀印度教臣民，要将他从部分学校课程中移除。然而，奇怪的是，对于一个坚定的印度教政治家沙希·塔鲁尔来说，我总体上认为他是一个印度人有充分理由引以为豪的人。迈索尔是一个强大的国家，延伸到南部印度可以想象的最大部分，他的迈索尔王国的子民享有已知世界最高的标准的生活，人均收入高于当时最高欧洲强国荷兰。装备精良，技术能力高，
rockets, which the British actually subsequently stole. He was an extremely effective general, a leader of troops in battle, who won more wars than he lost. But eventually, Tipu did lose the third Mysore war against the British, and the price was far higher than he was bargaining for. One of the stipulations of the peace that was struck between the East India Company and
火箭，英国人后来实际上偷走了这些火箭。他是一位极其高效的将军，战场上的军队领袖，赢得的战争比失败的多。但最终，蒂普确实输了与英国人的第三次迈索尔战争，其代价远比他讨价还价的要高得多。东印度公司和蒂普之间达成的和平协议的条件之一是，
Tipu was that two of Tipu's sons would be taken hostage by the British. Not just any British later, mind you. And those two sons were received by the at the time, the commander of the British forces, Lord Cornwallis, who a few years earlier had gained some notoriety here in the United States as the person who lost the Battle of Yorktown and with it concluded the American Revolution on American terms. Anyway, there he pops up in India a decade later and he takes these sons of Tipu Sultan. So the guy that failed to stop the American Revolution was not going to let this Indian warlord have his. So he held on to Tipu's sons.
蒂普的两个儿子将被英国人作为人质带走。请注意，不只是任何英国人。这两个儿子被当时的英国军队指挥官康沃利斯勋爵（Lord Cornwallis）接见，几年前他在美国因作为在约克镇战役中战败并以此在美方条件下结束美国革命的人而获得了一些恶名。无论如何，十年后他在印度冒出来，他带走了蒂普·苏丹的儿子们。所以那个未能阻止美国革命的家伙是不会让这个印度军阀如愿的。所以他扣留了蒂普的儿子们。
Do we know how Tipu reacted to the abduction of his children? You know, there's probably something more specific, but suffice to say there was a fourth miceaur or... So you can imagine that Tipu had gone through a fair amount of humiliation at British hands. So I think it's fairly understandable. You could see the depth of hatred that Tipu felt. But Tipu wasn't the only one who hated the British. That's where our other superpower steps into the picture.
我们知道蒂普对他的孩子被绑架有什么反应吗？你知道，可能有一些更具体的事情，但可以说有第四次迈索尔……所以你可以想象蒂普在英国人手下经历了一定程度的羞辱。所以我认为这相当可以理解。你可以看到蒂普感到的仇恨有多深。但蒂普不是唯一恨英国人的人。这就是我们的另一个超级大国登场的地方。
And that is the French. So this connection with the French is really important to the story of my source of scent and above all, I think it's demise. So in the 1790s, Britain and France are engaged in a huge global war, the Revolutionary Wars. And as a piece of this war, they are skirmishing in India. And Tippu just waged himself between them. Tipew helped the French and the French helped Tipew. They actually explored the idea of an alliance
那就是法国人。所以与法国人的这种联系对于迈索尔王国的崛起和最重要的是我认为它的消亡的故事非常重要。所以在1790年代，英国和法国正在进行一场巨大的全球战争，即革命战争。作为这场战争的一部分，他们在印度发生小规模冲突。而蒂普刚好介入了他们之间。蒂普帮助了法国人，法国人也帮助了蒂普。他们甚至探讨了这样一种联盟的想法，
that would throw the British out of India. So they had French advisors and soldiers, even, who came and drilled their own troops and taught them new tactics and, you know, doubtless racontuits for certain kinds of technology and certain kinds of maneuvers, which meant that, you know, to the extent that there was a technological gap between Western and Indian forces at that time,
将英国人赶出印度。所以他们有法国顾问甚至士兵，他们来训练他们自己的军队并教导他们新的战术，毫无疑问，他们为某些类型的手艺和某些类型的战术提供了讲诉，这意味着，你知道，在那种情况下，西方和印度军队之间存在技术差距，
which wasn't huge even to begin with, that gap was flattened. And not just methods to wage war. The French also supplied other technologies, including technology to make music. Tipus Tiger is pretty fascinating for a whole bunch of reasons, but one of them is that the manufacture of it is clearly Indo-European. That is the wood that it's made out of is Indian wood. That part was manufactured in India, but the mechanism inside that creates these noises is of European manufacture. This is how Tipu's tiger came to be. The embodiment of Tipu's rage against the British and the alliance between France and
最初差距也不是很大，那个差距被拉平了。不仅仅是作战方法。法国人还提供了其他技术，包括制造音乐的技术。蒂普之虎由于一大堆原因而非常迷人，但其中之一是它的制造显然是印欧风格的。也就是说，它所用的木材是印度的木材。那部分是在印度制造的，但内部产生这些噪音的机制是欧洲制造的。这就是蒂普之虎的由来。蒂普对英国人的愤怒以及法国与迈索尔之间联盟的化身，
Mysore, the same alliance that was about to be Tipu's undoing. And now a surprise appearance from a little known historical figure, somebody who in less than a year would become an icon of the French Revolution. Enter Napoleon Bonaparte. Napoleon, at the time, an up-and-coming general in the French Revolutionary Army, invades Egypt. For him, Egypt is a staging post on the way to India. Napoleon writes to Tipu Sultan and says, here I am in Egypt, you know, ready and waiting.
正是这个即将导致蒂普灭亡的联盟。现在，一个鲜为人知的历史人物惊喜现身，一个在不到一年内将成为法国革命偶像的人。拿破仑·波拿巴登场。当时的拿破仑是法国革命军队中一个崭露头角的将军，入侵了埃及。对他来说，埃及是通往印度的中转站。拿破仑写信给蒂普·苏丹说，我在这里，在埃及，你知道的，准备好了，随时待命。
I'm gonna send over my 10,000 men to come and join you and chase the British away. Well, that letter that Napoleon wrote was intercepted by the British off of Jeddah. The British jumped on the excuse or a pretext, if you will, to go after Tippu. In May of 1799, the East India Company surrounds Seringa Patam and they decide to go for it.
我要派我的1万名士兵来加入你，把英国人赶跑。好吧，拿破仑写的这封信在吉达（Jeddah）附近被英国人拦截了。英国人抓住了这个借口，或者如果你愿意的话，借口去追捕蒂普。1799年5月，东印度公司包围了塞林加帕坦姆，他们决定放手一搏。
They bombarded the thick fortifications and broke holes in it and set up their ladders and went running over and into the city. And then when they were in the city, there was hand-to-hand fighting in the streets, and among the dead that was discovered in a heap of bodies by one of the gates of the city at the end of this action,
他们轰炸了厚厚的防御工事，在上面砸出了洞，架起梯子，奔跑着冲进城里。然后当他们在城里时，街头发生了白刃战，在这场行动结束时，在城市的一个大门附近的一堆尸体中发现的死者中，
was that of Tipo Sultan himself. Court between the superpowers of France and Britain, between Cornwallis, a veteran of the American Revolution and Napoleon, soon to be leader of the French Revolution. Their lies, the Tiger of Mysore. Well, Tipu Sothans' fall was, I think, the end pretty much of any meaningful Indian resistance to steady British expansion. He was the last substantial monarch to be willing to fight the British.
就有蒂普·苏丹本人。夹在法国和英国这两个超级大国之间，夹在美洲革命老兵康沃利斯和即将成为法国革命领袖的拿破仑之间。那里躺着迈索尔之虎。好吧，我认为蒂普·苏丹的倒台基本上结束了印度对英国稳步扩张的任何有意义的抵抗。他是最后一个愿意与英国人战斗的大国君主。
How do you think Tipu would feel about his tiger sitting in the British institution? It's a statue that had been prepared essentially for him to actually demonstrate his contempt for the British to actually be in British hands would have been the ultimate act of him alleyation. So he would have been pretty, pretty upset about that. I think Tippu would be quite pleased because he was a very vain man. Someone who sees the tiger
你觉得蒂普会怎么看待他的虎坐在英国机构里？这是一个本应为他准备好用来展示他对英国人的蔑视的雕像，落入英国人手中将是最终的异化行为。所以他对此会感到非常非常难过。我认为蒂普会相当高兴，因为他是一个非常虚荣的人。看到这只虎的人
immediately wants to get drawn into the story about Tippu. So you have millions of people from around the world getting drawn into that story that would never happen if it was say in Bangalore which he would now be the capital of the Mysore state that he once ruled. Dr. Zarye Masani is a historian who was raised in India only to end up at Oxford University in the UK and as more people like Shashi Tharoa argue for the return of Tipu's Tiger to India. Zarye thinks there's parts of this story that we're missing. I mean, I'm all for certain objects that are of great iconic values, say religious value, being returned with something like Tipu's Tiger, the reason it survived is that it was shipped
会立刻被吸引到关于蒂普的故事中。所以你会吸引来自世界各地的数百万人被吸引到那个故事中，如果它在班加罗尔（他曾经统治的迈索尔邦现在的首都）的话，这永远不会发生。扎里·马萨尼博士（Dr. Zarye Masani）是一位历史学家，她在印度长大，最终来到英国牛津大学，随着越来越多的像沙希·塔鲁尔这样的人主张将蒂普之虎归还给印度。扎里认为这个故事有些部分我们遗漏了。我的意思是，我完全赞成归还某些具有巨大标志性价值的物品，比如宗教价值，但像蒂普之虎这样，它之所以能幸存下来，是因为它被运往
off to England and preserved. How did being in India would have just fallen to pieces eventually, because no one would have been particularly interested for a couple of hundred years. But Indian politician, Shashi Tharur, disagrees. There's something wrong about stealing items that belong to another people and then, you know, self-righteously claiming you look after them better than those who are entitled on them would. I mean, if somebody literally dug your father's grave up
英国并保存了下来。如果留在印度，最终就会四分五裂，因为几百年里不会有人对它特别感兴趣。但印度政治家沙希·塔鲁尔不同意。窃取属于另一个民族的物品，然后，你知道的，自以为是地声称你比那些有权拥有它们的人照顾得更好，这是不对的。我的意思是，如果有人字面意思上挖了你父亲的坟墓，
and put it on display in his backyard, would you feel that morality was on his side? I mean, it's that kind of story you're talking about. There is no tradition of museums in Indian culture. You know, pre-colonial India have no museums. So, I think this is very much a western fascination with antiquity that was transplanted to a country like India. I don't think it has that unique value.
并把它摆在他后院供人参观，你会觉得道德站在他那边吗？我的意思是，这就是你谈论的那种故事。印度文化中没有博物馆的传统。你知道，前殖民时期的印度没有博物馆。所以，我认为这非常像是对古董的西方迷恋，被移植到了像印度这样的国家。我认为它没有那种独特的价值。
And I think if it were returned to India now, it would just be another nationalistic sort of icon to be displayed somewhere of, you know, an Indian tiger eating a British soldier. I don't think that anyone would particularly be interested in the history beyond that. Except there is at least one person for whom it would mean much more than that. It took us a little while to track him down but eventually we managed to connect the call.
而且我认为如果现在把它归还给印度，它只会成为另一个民族主义的图腾，在某个地方展出，你知道的，一只印度老虎吃掉一个英国士兵。我不认为除了那之外会有人对历史特别感兴趣。除非至少有一个人，对他们来说这意味着比这更多的东西。我们花了一点时间才找到他，但最终我们成功接通了电话。
This might seem like a weird question but after all these years, do you think of yourself as royal? Oh no, I don't think you're as royal. I? No, I don't think you are self as royal. I feel I have not done anything much. I am an ordinary person. I just happen to be in the family. My name is Bhaktia Ralisha.
这听起来可能是一个奇怪的问题，但经过这么多年，你认为自己是皇室成员吗？哦，不，我不认为自己是皇室成员。我？不，我觉得你不会认为自己是皇室成员。我觉得我没有做过什么。我是一个普通人。我碰巧在这个家族里。我的名字叫巴赫蒂亚尔·阿里沙（Bhaktia Ralisha）。
Sixth generation descendant of Tipu Sutan from his Tenth son. By day Bhaktia Ralisha is a criminal lawyer in Karkara. It amazes me that even five generations or six generations down the line, people still want to connect and people want to know about him. So I just feel that what kind of charisma that man must have had, that is still, you know, kind of has a ripple effect on us till date. People still want to connect. They still have that kind of an aura about him,
他是蒂普·苏丹第十儿子的第六代直系后裔。白天，巴赫蒂亚尔·阿里沙是卡卡拉的一名刑事律师。令我惊奇的是，即使过了五代或六代人，人们仍然想建立联系，人们仍然想了解他。所以我只是觉得那个男人一定有着什么样的魅力，以至于至今仍然，你知道的，对我们产生着涟漪效应。人们仍然想建立联系。他们仍然对他怀有一种那样的光环，
which kind of wraps of on us. But the way Bakhtiath tells the story, being a descendant of Tipper, wasn't always a good thing. He was martyred in 1799. His family was kept as business. They were kept as business till about 1800 and six. So that is how our family came here.
这种光环在某种程度上笼罩着我们。但按照巴赫蒂亚尔讲述的故事，作为蒂普的后裔并不总是一件好事。他在1799年殉难。他的家人被当作生意对待。他们被当作生意对待直到1800年左右。所以这就是我们家族来到这里的方式。
Bucktier describes how the family were restricted from interacting with the locals, all going back to Mysel, they were exiled. Somehow we survived, we were left here to die. It's been a decline for the family from those times. How do you feel about that? How do you feel about that decline? Very unfortunate. All those people who went against the British, they're in bad shape in India.
巴赫蒂亚尔描述了家族如何被限制与当地人交往，一切都回到了迈索尔，他们被流放了。不知何故，我们活了下来，我们被留在这里等死。从那个时代起，这个家族一直在走下坡路。你对此有何感想？你对这种衰落有何感想？非常不幸。所有那些反对英国人的人，他们在印度的处境都很糟糕。
People who work with the British, they still have their royalty and everything. Even today, as usually happens, you know, I mean, once a king is vanquished and his entire They still have their royalty and everything, even today. As usually happens, you know, once a king is vanquished and his entire family has to suffer. So there's an unfortunate time when we're with the family. History is personal, it's messy. And sometimes in ways that we don't necessarily expect. So remember earlier when I said that Tipu Sultan ruled, sometimes brutally over Hindus,
那些与英国人合作的人，他们仍然拥有他们的皇室身份和一切。即使在今天，通常情况下，你知道的，我的意思是，一旦一个君主被击败，他的整个家族……他们仍然拥有他们的皇室身份和一切，即使在今天。正如通常发生的那样，你知道的，一旦一个君主被击败，他的整个家族都必须受苦。所以那是我们家族经历的不幸时期。历史是私人的，它是混乱的。有时以我们不一定预料到的方式。所以还记得我早些时候说过蒂普·苏丹有时对印度教徒进行残酷统治吗，
what I didn't realize is that a family includes my own family. You know, I've never been to India. Never been. No, I've never been. It's a surprise for me, why not? I'll rule over the world, you are traveling. That's the same thing because you are mum. Somehow it is your mum home land.
我没有意识到的是，这个家族包括我自己的家族。你知道，我从来没去过印度。从没去过。没有，我从来没去过。这对我来说是个惊喜，为什么不呢？我走遍全世界，你在旅行。这是一样的，因为你是妈妈。不知何故，那是你妈妈的祖国。
My mum's family does go back to India. Generations of Nairs were raised in the coastal regions of a place called Kerala. Kerala, which was colonized by Tipu, not by the British, by Tipu, who massacred about a hundred thousand local people transported many to slavery, with the heat practice slavery quite widely. My own Indian ancestors were almost definitely subjects of Tipu Sultana. I mean, Tipu's tiger belongs as much to me or you, I think, as it does to someone back in Mysore,
我妈妈的家族确实可以追溯到印度。几代奈尔人（Nairs）在喀拉拉邦（Kerala）一个叫喀拉拉的地方的沿海地区长大。喀拉拉，被蒂普殖民过，不是被英国人，而是被蒂普，他屠杀大约十万当地人，将许多人运送到奴役状态，热度广泛实行奴役。我自己的印度祖先几乎肯定是蒂普·苏丹的臣民。我的意思是，蒂普之虎既属于我和你，我认为，也属于迈索尔的某个人，
whether he was a war criminal or whether he was a great leader the heritage that's there belongs to all of us I did actually make it to the airport that day Let me tell you there's something about handing over your passport to make you really consider Who it is you belong to? To tell you the truth, I don't actually have a definitive opinion on British colonialism. But as an Australian who's a bit Indian, a bit Singaporean, a bit Irish, I do know that I wouldn't exist without him. And depending on where you're listening to this, there's a pretty good chance that you wouldn't either.
无论他是一个战犯还是一个伟大的领袖，那里的遗产都属于我们所有人。我那天确实赶上了机场。让我告诉你，交出护照这件事，会让你真正思考你究竟属于谁。说实话，我对英国殖民主义其实没有一个明确的看法。但作为一个有点印度血统、有点新加坡血统、有点爱尔兰血统的澳大利亚人，我确实知道如果没有它，我就不会存在。根据你听这个节目的地方，你大概率也不会存在。
In that library, Alice told me about four other objects. There's this whole kind of history of undescribed violence. Traject. Thousands of people are murdered. Surprising. You are weak. This is your feat. Some very strange objects from different corners of the earth.
在那个图书馆里，爱丽丝跟我讲了其他四件物品。这里有整整一种关于未被描述的暴力的历史。轨迹。成千上万的人被谋杀。令人惊讶。你很虚弱。这是你的壮举。来自世界各地的一些非常奇怪的物品。
And they tell a story. The story about how you and I ended up with the world that we have today. It's the story of us. Talled through some stuff. The British stole. Stuff the British stole was produced by Zoe Ferguson and myself. The executive producer is Amruth Asli and Julie Browning is the head of society and culture, mixing by Martin Perolta. If you want to know more about Alice Proctor, she's written a book called The Whole Picture,
它们讲述了一个故事。一个关于你我如何拥有今天这个世界的长篇故事。这是我们的故事。通过一些东西讲述。英国人偷走的。《那些英国人偷走的东西》由佐伊·弗格森（Zoe Ferguson）和我自己制作。执行制片人是阿姆鲁特·阿斯利（Amruth Asli），朱莉·勃朗宁（Julie Browning）是社会与文化负责人，混音由马丁·佩罗尔塔（Martin Peralta）完成。如果你想了解更多关于爱丽丝·普罗特的信息，她写了一本书叫做《全景》（The Whole Picture），
which is available now. This is a production of ABC R.N. RN, it was created and written by me. I'm Mark Fonell and he is a hint for next episode. It wants to hug you. See ya. I talk with series creator and presenter Mark Fennel after this. My name is Mark Fenn, and amongst other things, I'm the creator of a podcast series called Stuff the British Stole. Originally, the title had another word in it that was not stuff.
现在即可收听。这是ABC R.N.的节目，由我创作并撰写。我是马克·福内尔，这是下一集的预告：它想拥抱你。再见。稍后我将与该系列的创作者兼主持人马克·芬内尔交谈。我的名字是马克·芬（Mark Fenn），除其他身份外，我还是一个名为《大英帝国盗走的东西》（Stuff the British Stole）的播客系列的创作者。最初，这个标题里还有另一个词，不是“stuff”。
It was another S word, but multiple broadcasts around the world told me that I should change that. But the word I'm glad didn't change was the stolen part. Yeah, absolutely. So you did this for the ABC, the Australian broadcasting corporation, your based Australia. When you start with the name, stuff, the British store and you're in Australia, do you just begin with like, just ring broadly to the land around you?
那是另一个以S开头的词，但世界各地的多家广播公司告诉我应该把它改掉。不过我很高兴没有被改掉的词是“被盗”这个部分。是的，完全同意。所以你这是为ABC（澳大利亚广播公司）制作的，你 base 在澳大利亚。当你从“大英帝国盗走的东西”这个名字开始，而且你又在澳大利亚时，你是不是只是从广泛环顾你身边的土地开始的？
Or well, it actually, it actually started with a conversation with a friend of mine. And she's Lebanese and we used to host a TV show together. And we were just saying, we both love going to museums, but when we were there, you would always just like close your eyes and point, open your eyes and go, oh yeah, that was stolen from Insert Country here. And then we looked at each other and then we looked at the landscape around us and went, oh, everything. And I think that was a good starting point. And I think when I look for stories and projects and
或者说，其实它最初是和我的一个朋友聊天聊出来的。她是黎巴嫩人，我们曾一起主持过一个电视节目。我们当时在说，我们俩都喜欢去博物馆，但当我们在那里时，你总是会闭上眼随便指一个，然后睁开眼说：“哦，是的，那是从[插入国家名]偷来的。”然后我们看着彼此，接着环顾身边的风景，心想：“哦，一切都是。”我觉得这是一个很好的起点。而且我认为当我寻找故事、项目以及
things to create and work on, I'm usually looking for a small doorway into a big world. And this struck me as the perfect way to do history, to do colonialism without, and I'm doing air quotes here, doing history and colonialism. It's something that's digestible and it has intrigue. And I think that was kind of the heart of it. And the way it really kicked off for me is I happened to be on my way to London and I was going over for an award that I knew I was going to lose. So I was like, I need to think of something else
想要创作和从事的事情时，我通常是在寻找通往一个宏大世界的小门。这让我觉得它是进行历史、进行殖民主义研究的完美方式，而且——我在这里比划着空气引号——不用以那种说教的方式来做历史和殖民主义。它是那种易于消化且引人入胜的东西。我想这差不多就是它的核心所在。而它真正对我有如神助般展开的契机是，我恰好在去伦敦的路上，我要去参加一个明知自己会落选的颁奖典礼。所以我当时就在想，我得想点别的
worthwhile to do on this trip. So I arranged to meet up with a historian who I had kind of heard of before. And she sort of just blew my mind. And she's actually, the voice you hear at the beginning, Alice Proctor. And it was a real like on a whim, like let's just catch up and I might record it.
在这趟旅行中值得做的事。于是我安排了一位我之前略有耳闻的历史学家见面。她简直让我大开眼界。她其实就是你在开头听到的那个声音，爱丽丝·普罗クター（Alice Proctor）。这真是一个突发奇想的决定，比如“我们碰个面吧，我兴许还能把它录下来”。
And suddenly, she kind of crystallized the whole thing for me. And I was like, oh, there's a world of stories here that you can tell that tell us, not just about, it's not just about a femur, but they tell us about ourselves and it tells us about how we ended up with the world. As I said in the series, we have to die and I think that was it was a bit of a lot bulb moment. Yeah, yeah. So how did you pick the different objects to focus on because as you said, you know, like there's a lot of examples of stuff the British store. So we heard about one of them,
突然之间，她为我把整件事情的思路理清了。当时我就想：“哦，这里有一个充满故事的世界，你可以通过它们来讲述不仅关于——它不只关乎一根股骨，它们还讲述了我们自己，讲述了我们是如何走到今天这个世界的。”正如我在节目中所说，我们必须深入挖掘，我觉得这有点像是一个灵光乍现的时刻。是的，是的。那么你是如何挑选不同的物件来作为焦点的呢？因为正如你所说，你知道的，有很多关于大英帝国偷走的东西的例子。所以我们听说了其中一个，
but of the other ones in this series and you as you told me that you're going to make another set of these these episodes. You know, what is the thing that sort of that sort of peaks your interest when it comes to a certain type of object? You're totally correct. There are a gazillion things and that's a very technical mathematical term that the British stole. I think it's there's a few bars that it needs to clear. So it likes to have a few internal turning points as an object itself in terms of the history that it tells. But ultimately what it comes down to is it has to, you have to be able to draw a line.
但在本系列的其它物件中，而且正如你告诉过我的，你还打算制作另一组这样的剧集。你知道的，当涉及到某种特定类型的物件时，究竟是什么东西能激起你的兴趣呢？你完全说得对。有成千上万件——这是一个非常专业且数学上的术语——大英帝国偷走的东西。我认为它需要通过几个门槛。作为物件本身，它最好在它所讲述的历史方面有几个内部转折点。但归根结底，它必须能够让你画出一条线。
In some point in all that fishing and reading old papers and whatnot, you have to be able to draw a line between the object being taken and today. And usually I find that's a person or a family, something that somebody for whom it matters a great deal and they kind of crystallize it. It can never be a femoral. It always has to connect to something emotional. And it's funny when I first started making the series, a lot of people were like, well,
在所有那些搜寻和阅读旧文件等等的过程中，你必须能够在被掠夺的物件和今天之间画出一条线。通常我发现那是一个人或一个家庭，某种对某人至关重要的人或事，他们将这种情感具象化了。它绝不能是短暂而虚无的。它必须始终与某种情感相连。说来有趣，当我刚开始制作这个系列时，很多人都在问：“好吧，
what are you going to do? The Portuguese? And what are you going to do? The Nazis. I'm like, look, that heaps the stuff with stolen their two. But I think the thing that the British Empire is, the British Empire shaped so much of our lives. Like the fact that you and I, we're separated by thousands of miles and kilometers right now, but the fact that you and I can communicate is because we both speak English. And if you speak English, you've been touched by the British Empire. And so I think it's, it's this idea that it does, it has this huge shaping force that sits underneath our lives in the way that is so ubiquitous that it's almost invisible, right? Unless you take
你打算做什么？葡萄牙人？那你打算做什么？纳粹？”我说：“听着，他们也掠夺了一大堆东西。”但我认为大英帝国之所以不同，是因为大英帝国塑造了我们生活的如此之多。比如你和我现在相隔数千英里和公里，但你我之所以能够交流，是因为我们都说英语。如果你说英语，你就已经受到了大英帝国的触动。所以我觉得它——它有这种巨大的塑造力量，潜藏在我们的生活中，其无处不在的程度几乎令人察觉不到，对吧？除非你花时间
the time to look at it through a digestible lens. And as it turns out, weird objects sitting in museums, quite digestible. So the even the title indicates a point of view about it. And so I'm curious to know the different responses you might have gotten from the podcast, maybe from people who might vehemently disagree with you with even the verb stall. Yeah. The title is Stride and it's right. But also once you get into the stories, you realize the stories are really complicated.
通过一个易于消化的镜头去审视它。事实证明，那些静静躺在博物馆里的奇怪物件，相当容易消化。因此，甚至连标题都表明了一种观点。所以我很好奇你从这个播客中收到的不同反应，也许来自那些可能强烈不同意你使用“偷窃”这个动词的人。是的。标题是直白且准确的。但一旦你深入到这些故事中，你就会意识到这些故事其实非常复杂。
And there are, and I say to people, you know, when we're approaching them to be in the series, we are open to having the conversation about it being contested. And we are open to you saying, no, it was not stolen, it was a gift or whatever you want to say. What it really comes down to for me is, it's about nuance, right? So you have to be able to be honest with the audience and go, well, this person says this,
而且有——我对人们说，你知道的，当我们接洽他们参与这个节目时，我们是愿意就它是“有争议的”这一点展开对话的。我们也愿意听你说：“不，它不是偷来的，这是一个礼物”或者任何你想说的话。对我来说，归根结底，这关乎细微差别，对吧？所以你必须能够对听众诚实，然后说：“好吧，这个人这么说，
but if you look into it, it isn't backed up, or if you go down another pathway, it sounds like it isn't. And I think a big part of why I like this medium, the thing that we make, is that it allows you to take an audience down the pathway and I think that kind of respects your intelligence that you can hold more than one idea at once. And when we look at the past, there's a tendency to either focus only on the good things or only on the bad things.
但如果你深入调查，就会发现它并没有得到证实；或者如果你换一条思路，听起来似乎也不是那么回事。”我认为我喜欢这种媒介、我们所制作的东西的一个重要原因，在于它能引导听众顺着一条思路走下去，而且我认为这尊重了你的智力，即你可以同时容纳不止一种观点。当我们回顾过去时，往往倾向于要么只关注好的事情，要么只关注坏的事情。
My attitude to particularly colonialism is, you will encounter these arguments and people say, well, if it weren't for colonialism, you wouldn't have laws and you wouldn't have railroads. But then at the other end, the spectrum is like, because of colonialism, there was genocides and there was children taken away from families, horrendous stuff. My attitude to history and the thing that this series taught me is that those two things don't ever balance each other out. And they definitely don't cancel each other out.
我对待殖民主义（尤其是殖民主义）的态度是，你总会遇到这些争论，人们会说：“嗯，要不是因为殖民主义，你们就不会有法律，也不会有铁路。”但另一方面，光谱的另一端是：“因为殖民主义，发生了大屠杀，孩子们被强行带离家庭，”这些骇人听闻的事情。我对待历史的态度以及这个系列教给我的东西是，这两者永远无法互相抵消。它们绝对无法互相抵消。
All they do is they coexist. And I think we, as a species, are smart enough to hold both of those ideas at the same time and not try and force them to balance each other out in some sort of historical weighing match. It doesn't work that way. And I think what's good about stories like this is you can actually guide the audience through those things.
它们所做的只是共存。我认为我们作为一个物种，足够聪明，可以同时持有这两种观点，而不会试图强迫它们在某种历史天平上互相抵消。事情不是那样运作的。我认为像这样的小故事的好处在于，你可以真正引导听众走过这些事情。
And we emerge out the other end with a more sort of complex understanding. Like I say to people, like, I want you to stand in the mess. Like I want you to feel the mess. I like the idea of stand in the mess. Like I want you to feel the mess. I like the idea of standing in the mess. I mean, what we have discovered a little bit in the repatriation sort of discussion is that who you're repatriating to is actually pretty complicated
而我们在另一端破茧而出时，会对事物有更复杂的理解。就像我对人们所说的那样：“我想让你站在混乱之中。我想让你去感受这种混乱。”我喜欢“站在混乱之中”这个说法。我是说，我们在遣返问题的讨论中稍微发现的一点是，你究竟要把东西遣返给谁，其实相当复杂。
because it isn't the monarch or the controller of a state that once was. I mean, there's a brand new government there and there's descendants of those people. And it becomes like, well, I don't even know where this object belongs, even if you were inclined to give it back anyway. Yeah, and in the next episode of the series,
因为那并不是曾经的君主或国家的统治者。我是说，那里有一个崭新的政府，还有那些人的后代。这就变成了：“好吧，我甚至不知道这个物件该归属何处，即便你本来就倾向于把它还回去。”是的，而在该系列的下一集中，
that is a very core problem, where basically we've got two guys who basically come into possession of something that belongs to a ruler that no longer exists. And then the government in Nigeria were like, well, we can have it back if it's a gigantic political act, and we can put on a song and dance about it. But that's not what the people that own the object currently wanted.
这是一个非常核心的问题，基本上我们遇到了两个人，他们无意中占有了一件属于一个不复存在的统治者的东西。然后尼日利亚政府的态度是：“好吧，如果这是一个巨大的政治行为，我们可以把它拿回来，我们可以为此载歌载舞一番。”但这不是目前拥有这个物件的人们想要的。
And so there's a huge amount of challenge, there's a huge swath of challenges that happen there. And actually, it's something that comes up all the time with this series, which is like, you get to the point of like, you've told the story of how it ended up where it is. And then in an effort to find a conclusion, you're like, ah, there is none because we're still living with the consequences. And so you have to kind of dig a little deeper
所以这里有巨大的挑战，有海量的挑战发生在那里。实际上，这也是这个系列中经常出现的情况，也就是：当你讲完它是如何流落到今天这个地方的故事之后，为了寻找一个结局，你会想：“啊，根本没有结局，因为我们仍然在与这些后果共存。”所以你必须稍微更深入地挖掘，
and go, well, what, if the, there's the macro-story of the object and what you do with it, but then it's like, what does that object tell you? And what does the story of that object tell you? And usually it tells you about a culture that's been interrupted and families that have been interrupted. And if you can find something, and this is what I, this is what gives me up at night, if I can find something that the answer is that, usually there's an ending, and it's not necessarily the ending to the object because the object is static, but the people,
然后思考：“好吧，如果说有关于这个物件的宏大叙事以及你对它做了什么，但随之而来的是，这个物件究竟向你诉说了什么？这个物件的故事向你诉说了什么？”通常它讲述的是一个被打断的文化和被打断的家庭。如果你能找到某种东西——这也是我、这正是让我夜不能寐的原因——如果我能找到一个答案，通常会有一个结局，而这不一定是指物件的结局，因为物件是静止的，但人，
they keep going. And if you can find something that returns justice and conclusion to them, then I kind of feel like I've done my job somewhat, maybe. So, you know, when it comes to the whole concept of using mundane objects or maybe even fantastic objects to use as a lens to view ourselves in the world, I mean, this is something that's very near and dear to the heart of us at 99PI. And as such, you know, we get pitches about the repatriation of colonial objects like quite often. And we've done a few of these stories.
他们一直在前行。如果你能找到某种能为他们恢复正义和圆满的东西，那么我就会觉得我多少完成了一点工作，也许吧。所以，你知道的，当谈到使用平凡的物件甚至是奇幻的物件作为镜头来审视我们自己和这个世界这一整个概念时，这是我们99PI团队深感亲切和挚爱的事物。正因如此，你知道的，我们经常收到关于遣返殖民物件的选题。而且我们也做过其中一些故事。
You can't do them all. I mean, maybe you can do them all, actually. But, of these stories. You can't do them all. I mean, maybe you can do them all, actually. But we can't do them all. Why do you think this topic it feels so relevant right now? Like, it really seems to be people are thinking about it in a way that I've never encountered before. We are re-examining history really intensely
你不可能把它们全做完。我是说，也许你其实可以全做完。但是，对于这些故事。你不可能把它们全做完。我是说，也许你其实可以全做完。但我们无法全部做到。为什么你觉得这个话题现在感觉如此切合时宜？听起来人们似乎正在以一种我从未遇到过的方式思考它。我们正在全球范围内对历史进行非常深入的重新审视。
across the world right now. And I think there's a sense that history has been unbalanced in how it was taught. Like in my country in Australia, indigenous Australians have been around for 60,000 years. The oldest continuous culture on Earth. But when I was going up through school, the way it works is that you get one page
而且人们有一种感觉，即历史在教授时一直是不平衡的。比如在我的家乡澳大利亚，澳大利亚原住民已经在那里生活了6万年。这是地球上最古老的持续延绵的文化。但当我上学的时候，它是这样运作的：你只有一页纸是关于澳大利亚原住民的。
of their indigenous people in Australia. And then Captain Cook arrived, and that's when history starts. And I think that's true of a lot of Western, The way it works is that you get one page of their indigenous people in Australia and then Captain Cook arrived and that's when history starts, right? And I think that's true of a lot of you know Western, Western histories. And there's a sense now of we need to go back and re-examine the past. And certainly in academic and historical societies that's been happening for a long time, but I think it's pushed out into the wider world where people are suddenly looking around them at the land in which they walk and going, huh, how did we get here?
然后库克船长来了，历史就从那里开始了。我认为许多西方历史也是如此。它是这样运作的：你只有一页纸是关于澳大利亚原住民的，然后库克船长来了，历史就从那里开始，对吧？我认为许多你知道的西方、西方历史也是如此。现在人们有一种感觉，我们需要回过头去重新审视过去。当然，在学术界和历史社群中，这种做法已经进行很长时间了，但我认为它已经扩展到了更广阔的世界，人们突然环顾他们脚下的土地，然后想：“嗯，我们是怎么走到这一步的？”
And I do think movements like Black Lives Matter has been really instructive and sparking that not just in the US, but around the world. It's funny with statues, I don't care, I spare with me. Statues are such a fascinating thing because when you build a statue to somebody, you're not leaving a lot of room for nuance
而且我确实认为像“黑人的命也是命”这样的运动在引发这一思考方面非常具有启发意义，不仅在美国，而且在世界各地。说来有趣，说到雕像，我并不在乎——请听我把话说完。雕像是一件如此迷人的事物，因为当你为某人建造一座雕像时，你并没有为围绕这座雕像的细微差别留下太多空间。
around that statue. You build statues to heroes, right? And if that person is anything less than, or more than, a hero, you're putting a lot of pressure on that plaque to tell that story. And most of the time those plaques don't tell that story. That's my whole thing.
你为英雄建造雕像，对吧？如果那个人的表现哪怕有一点点不如英雄，或者超出了英雄的范畴，你就把巨大的压力压在了那块牌匾上，要求它去讲述那个故事。而大多数时候，那些牌匾并没有讲述那个故事。这就是我的全部观点。
I'm at a podcast to address the inadequacy of plaques and museums. It's a weird life choice, but I back it. I fully support it. So our audience has listened to episode one about T.Poo Stiker, which is like a really fantastic object that makes sound and it's colorful and odd in many ways. Could you tease some of the other ones from this series and maybe even tease some of the objects you're working on for series number two? So we have objects that were taken from an African nation in the middle of a massacre. A really specific massacre. We have a dog that was taken from China.
我做播客是为了弥补博物馆牌匾的不足。这是一个奇怪的人生选择，但我支持它。我完全支持它。所以我们的听众已经收听了关于T.Poo Stiker的第一集，这是一个非常奇妙的物件，它能发出声音，色彩斑斓且在许多方面都很奇特。你能剧透一下这个系列的其它一些物件吗，甚至剧透一下你正在为第二季筹备的一些物件？我们有一些从处于大屠杀中的一个非洲国家掠夺来的物件。一场非常特定的大屠杀。我们有一只从中国被掠夺走的狗。
There is a tattoo, or a body part that was tattooed that was taken from New Zealand. And then there was something that was taken from my home country. And at the moment, we're currently working on another five episodes. And all I'll say is that I'm spending a lot of time with Greek people.
有一个纹身，或者说一个被纹过身并从新西兰被掠夺走的身体部位。然后还有从我的祖国被掠夺走的东西。目前，我们正在制作另外五集。我只想说，我花了很多时间与希腊人在一起。
And I can't possibly imagine why I would be talking to Greek people. It's not like they have anything major stolen from them by the British that I can think of. So, Mark, thank you so much for talking with us. And for sharing your stories and allowing us to share with our audience, because I know they're going to just dig the hell out of it.
我简直无法想象为什么我会跟希腊人交谈。这又不是说他们有什么重大物件被英国人偷走了，我想不出有这回事。所以，马克，非常感谢你与我们交谈。并分享你的故事，允许我们与我们的听众分享，因为我知道他们一定会超级喜欢它的。
So, thank you, Hank Sramon. 99% invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed music and tech production by our director of Sound Sean Rihau. Our executive producer is Delaney Hall. Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Barube, Christopher Johnson,
所以，谢谢你，Hank Sramon。《99%隐形》本周由埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）制作，我们的音响总监肖恩·里豪（Sean Real）负责混音、音乐和技术制作。我们的执行制作人是德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。柯特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括维维安·勒（Vivian Le）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson），
Losh Madon, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Andrew Davies at ABC. We are part of a Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown,
洛什·马东（Losh Madon）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我——罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。特别感谢ABC的安德鲁·戴维斯（Andrew Davies）。我们现在是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，总部设在潘多拉大厦（Pandora building）以北六个街区，
Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99pi.org, or on Instagram and Reddit too. You should check out this new Stitcher series called Toxic, all about Britain Spears and her disturbing conservatorship and the group of fans trying to end it as told by some of those fan spearheading the movement.
位于美丽的上加州奥克兰市（Oakland, California）。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（Roman Mars），或者关注节目@99pi.org，也可以在Instagram和Reddit上找到我们。你应该去听听这个名为《Toxic》的新Stitcher系列节目，它全部关于布兰妮·斯皮尔斯（Britney Spears）以及她令人不安的监护权，还有那一群试图结束这种状况的粉丝，正如该运动的一些先锋粉丝所讲述的那样。
It's a fascinating podcast. You can find a link to it and other Stitcher shows I love and every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. I'm going to steal something from the British. You're listening to a Stitcher podcast from Sirius Exxon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个迷人的播客。你可以在99pi.org上找到它的链接，以及我喜爱的其他Stitcher节目和99PI的每一期往期节目。我要从英国人那里偷点东西。你收听的是来自Sirius XM的Stitcher播客。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。